Selamlar 9. sınıf tayfam. Eşlik,
benzerlikte artık anlatılması gereken
her şeyi anlattık, bitirdik. Öglit
bağıntısına da bir sonraki ders
geçeceğim. Sizden gelen taleple ne
yapıyorum? Soru çözümü yapıyorum. Hani
bu anlattığımız eşlik benzerlikle ilgili
çözebileceğimiz güzel tipte soruları
sizler için seçtim. Onları beraber
çözeceğiz. Bir nevi genel tekrar gibi
bir ders olacak. Hiç uzatmıyorum. Elimde
kalemim, önümde ders notlarım. Çönder
gelsin dedim. Arkadaş kullandığımız
modülde size ödev olarak bıraktığım
ölçme testlerinden ölçme 4'ün tamamını
çözeceğim. Ölçme 6'nın da şu son kaç
sorusu oluyor? 4 sorusunu çözeceğiz.
Beraber böylelikle güzel bir tekrar
yapmış olacağız. Hemen bak bakalım
birinci soru ne ile ilgili arkadaş?
Benzerlikle ilgili. Tales teoremi ile
ilgili. Direkt bu soru Talest'ten de
çözülebilir. Bir. İkincisi bir de
nereden çözülebiliyordu? Benzerlikten.
Mesela ben senin yerinde olsam sınavda
ben genelde şöyle çözüyorum.
Benzerlikten çözüyorum. Hemen buradan
dikmemi attım hocam. Attım. Bu dikme
sayesinde şuranın 5 olduğunu gördüm.
Şuranın 10 olduğunu gördüm. Yukarıdaki
3'ü aşağıya 3 olarak, en aşağıya da 3
olarak düştüm. 12'den 3'ü çıkardım
buradaki parçaya 9. X'ten 3'ü çıkardım
buraya x - 3 kaldı. Dedim ki artık
benzerlik devreye girdi hocam. Küçüğün
büyüğü oranı küçüğün büyüğü oranına ne
olmak zorunda? eşit olmak zorunda. Yani
kısaca 10/15 değeri x - 3/ 9 değerine
eşittir. 5'e böldüm 2 5'e böldüm 3. 3
ile 9'u sadeleştirdim 3 içler dışlar
çarpım yaptım. 2 kere 3 6 x - 3'e eşitse
x'in değeri buradan 9 birimdir. Şimdi bu
çözebileceğimiz yöntemlerden birincisi
ama ben istiyorum ki diğerini de bilin.
Hani oradan da nasıl mantığın geldiğini
görün. Burası tamamen oran orantı
mantığıyla ilerliyor. Yalnız dikkat et.
Şimdi 10 la 5'i kendi arasında
sadeleştirsem K'ye 2K kalır mı? Tales
teoremi diyor ki bak diyor buradan 3
aldım diyor. Buraya gelince ne oldu
diyor? 12 oldu diyor. Aradaki fark kaç?
9. Biz bu aradaki farkı kaç K'de
sağladık? 3K'de sağladık. 3Kde 9 birim
arttırdım aşağı inerken. Peki buradan
buraya giderken kaç tane K geçiyorum? 2
tane K geçiyorum. 3 tane K'de 9 birim
artarsam 2K'de ne kadar artarım? 6 birim
artarım. Doğru orantı 9'u 3'e böldüm 3 k
başına 3 artarsa 2k de 6 artar. Burası
3, burası 6 artarak geliyor. X = 9. Bu
da çözebileceğin 2inci pratik yöntem.
Biraz da seri çözüyorum buradaki
soruları. Çünkü konuyu zaten bir tür
dinledin. Dinlemediysen mutlaka dinle.
Bu ders tek başına bir işe yaramaz.
Yoksa KLM üçgen. Paralellikler verilmiş.
4 tane paralel doğruyu birbiriyle
görüyorsun. SN'yi istiyor. Şurayı
istiyor. Yani şuraya X dedim. Nasıl
yapacağız hocam? Bak şuradaki üçgenler
benzer olduğu için 1in 2'ye göre oranı
değil mi? 1 birime 2 birim gidiyor.
Dikkat et. Mesela şuraya k dersem burası
2 2. O zaman tabanlar oranında 1'e 2
olur mu? Olur. Devam ediyorum bak 1in 3
birime oranı. O zaman burası x ise tabii
burası 2x olacak. Burası x ise buraya
kaç x kalır hocam? 3x kalır. Bundan yana
sıkıntımız var mı? Yok. Şimdi büyük
resme bakıyorum. Hocam bu üçgenin büyük
üçgene oranına bakacağız kısaca. Bak
burada 1 k var. 1 2 3 4k burada var. O
halde oranımız k'ye 4K. Bu oran neye
eşit olmalı? Tabanlar oranına eşit
olmalı. Tabanlarımız ne? 3x'e 24. K'ler
birbirini 7. 4'ler de birbirini 7. 3 4 x
6 24. O yüzden buraya 6 yazacağım.
Yazamadım. Şimdi içler dışlar çarpımı
yapıyorum. 3 tane x eğer 6ysa x'in
değeri buradan kaç gelecektir? 2 birim
gelecektir. Bunlar böyle hani sınav
ayarın yani sınav ayarında sorular tabii
de hani sınavda çözüyormuşum gibi
çözmüyorum. Gerçekten test tekniğiyle
çözüyorum. Sınav mantığıyla hızlı pratik
bir şekilde nasıl çözerim onu anlatmaya
çalışıyorum. Tamam mı? Yoksa uzun uzun
benzerlikleri yazman lazım gerçek
sınavda KLM üçgen. Biz bunu zaten
derslerimizde yaptık. Burada biraz
pratik biraz bakış açısı kazanmaya
çalışıyoruz. Hocam RP paralelmiş KM'ye.
KM ile RP birbirine paralel. Tamam. 6
birim, 2 birim, 5 birim hepsi şekil
üstünde var. Benim ilk görmem gereken
nokta neresi? Hemen ne yapacağım? Bak,
keçeli kalemimi elime aldım. Mor
kalemimi de aldım. Şurada neyi çizdim?
Kelebek üçgeni çizdim. Ya da Mehmet
hocan sana ne demişti? Papyon üçgen
demişti. Bu kelebek üçgendeki oran
nedir? Bak burada biraz açı yazmamda
fayda var. Şuraya çizik açısı dedim.
Şuraya da çızık açısı dedim. Çizik
açılarının karşısında sırayla 2'ye 5
var. Demek ki oran 2'ye 5. Örneğin ben
buraya 2m dersem burası 5m olacak. Ya da
buraya 2k dersem burası kaç k olacak? 5k
olacak. Süper. Şimdi sorunun benden
istediği nokta x. Burası büyük üçgenle
de küçük üçgen yine bana verilen
paralellikten yola çıkarak söylerim ki
benzer üçgenler. O halde küçük üçgenin
büyük üçgene oranı küçük tabanın büyük
tabana oranına eşittir. Zaten küçük
tabanın büyük tabana oranı 2/5. Geldim.
6/ Bak buranın tamamı x + 6. Birçok
öğrenci genelde burayı karıştırıyor
unutuyor. Lütfen buraya dikkat. x + 6
yazdım. 2 ile 6'yı sadeleştirdim. 3.
İçler dışlar çarpımı yaptım. x + 6 = 3 x
5'ten 15. X'in cevabı eşittir kaç birim
geldi? 9 birim olarak bulundu. 3. soruda
biter mi? Biter hocam. Geldim 4
numaraya. K LPN dörtgen. KL Mm üçgen.
Bana verilen paralellikler var. 5 3 20
var. X'in değeri benden isteniyor.
Nereden başlarsın soruya? Bir kere şu
paralellikten ilk gördüğün soruya bakar
bakmaz göreceğin şey arkadaş benim
buradaki bir kere kelebeği görmem lazım.
Bak soruları ben de seninle birlikte ilk
defa görüyorum aslında. Hani harbiden
ilk bakışımı söylemeye çalışıyorum.
Hocam bak burada ne var? Benzerlik var.
Hatta uzatmaya gerek yok. Bu benzerlik
oranı kaç? 5'e 3. Örneğin şuraya 5k
dersem şuraya kaç k derim? 3k derim.
Hemen yazdım. 5k'ye 3k. Bunların karşı
kenarları da benzer oranda olmak
zorunda. Sadece ikizkenar üçgen
değillerse farklı harflerle gösterilir.
Tamam mı? 5m'ye 3m şeklinde gösterdim.
Yine geldim büyük üçgenin ve küçük
üçgenin oranlarına. Tabii ben önce
küçükten başladım. Küçüğün büyüğe oranı
küçüğün büyüğe oranı da ne olmak
zorunda? Eşit olmak zorunda. Yukarısı 5m
5 3 daha ne yaptı? 8m oranı eşit olmalı.
20/x + 3 oranına. Kabul müyüz? Güzel.
Şimdi m'ler birbirini 7te 20 sadeleşti.
4. İçler dışlar çarpımı yaptım. x + 3 =
4 x 8 32'dir. x buradan kaç gelecektir?
29 birim gelecektir. Tatlı mı? Tatlı.
Güzel de bir soru çözümü mü yaptık yoksa
işlem hatası mı yaptık? Bakıyorum.
Hayır. X + 3. Doğru. Oradaki taban x + 3
olacak. Bir anda acaba dedim işlem
hatası mı yaptık? Hayır. Hiçbir hatamız
yok. Anlaştık mı? Var mı kafayata
bakılan bir nokta? Gel hocam. Bunu nasıl
yapacağız? Hemen baktım. Bak bir kere
görüyorsun değil mi? Bunun buna oranı,
bunun buna oranı, bunun buna oranı,
bunun buna oranı. Tüm oranlar birbirine
eşit. Çünkü şunların paralellikleri
sırayla ne yapılmış burada? Verilmiş.
Uzunluklar verilmiş. Ama burada bir oran
var. O oranı da hemen takip etmem lazım.
FP oranı eee 2K'ymiş. FK oranı K'ymiş.
Güzel. Benzerlik oranı malum artık. X +
Y kaç birimdir? Benden bunu istiyor.
Mantık ne hocam? 2K'nin yani küçüğün
büyüğe oranı yani 3k'ye oranı eşit
olmalı. Bak bu üçgende de aynı, bu
üçgende de aynı, her birinde aynı.
Tabanlar için de bu kurallar geçerli mi?
Geçerli. O zaman bu oranların hepsi aynı
şekilde tabanları için de geçerli olacak
şekilde ne yapılabilir? Yazılabilir.
Önce şu ikiliyi çözüyorum. 2/3 e= x/1'e
3 ile 18 sadeleşti 6 x = buradan kaç
birim geldi? 12 birim geldi. Aynı
mantıkla 2/3 eşitse eğer 14/ y'ye 2 ile
14 sadeleşti 7 y = 3 kere 7'den ne
geldi? 21 birim geldi. Ardından ne
yapıyorum? X ile y'yi topluyorum ki
buradan da cevabım ne gelecektir?
Toplamı isteniyordu benden. 33 birim
gelir. Doğru cevap 33 birimdir. Seri
seri seri. Benim derdim burada seri soru
çözmek. Uzun uzun zaten bunların
çözümleri var YouTube'da da. Ama ben
sana ekstra böyle kendimde nasıl seri
çözülüyor onu gösteriyorum. KLM üçgen.
Diklikler var. 5 tane KS 2 tane SM'ye
eşit. NS de 8 birim. PRX kaç birimdir?
Benden bunu istiyorum hocam. Herkes
karşısındakinin katına eşit mesela değil
mi? KS uzunluğuna ne diyorum ben? KS
nerede? Şurada. 2K birimdir. SM
uzunluğuna ne diyorum hocam? 5k
birimdir. Buraya kadar bir sıkıntımız
var mı? Yok. 8 birim, x birim. Bunlar
zaten şekil üzerinde gözüküyorlar. Ben
de diyorum ki hocam şimdi nasıl
kuracağız bağlantıyı? Hiçbir bağlantı
yok. Şimdi şu doğrudan buraya dikme
atmışım. Buradan da dik mi atmışım?
Hocam bariz bir şekilde bu doğruların
birbirine paralel olduğunu görüyoruz
galiba değil mi? Bunlar dik çünkü
tabana. Bunlar paralel. Ama bir eksiklik
var. İşte o eksikliği senin tamamlaman
gerekiyor. M'den KL'ye paralel pardon
dik olacak şekilde ve diğerlerine
paralel olacak şekilde doğrumu çektim.
Çektiğim doğru bana şunu söylüyor bak.
Oran veriyor bir anda. 1e 2 oran. Buraya
k dedim. Oraya aşağıda da k dediğim için
m diyelim. Hadi. Şurası 2m değil mi? O
zaman şunu söyleyebilir miyim hocam?
Burası x ise şuranın tamamı kaç x olmak
zorunda? 2x olmak zorunda. Şimdi 2x'e
kadar getirdim. Şimdi tersten bakıyorum
şuradaki üçgene. Burada bir üçgen daha.
Büyük ve küçük üçgenler var. Küçüğün
büyüğe oranı küçüğün büyüğe oranına
eşittir. 2K'nin 7k'ye oranı 5 2 daha 7.
8'in 2x'e oranına eşittir. K'ler
birbirinin 7. 8ile 2 sadeleşti 4 ile 2
sadeleşti 2 içler dışlar çarpımı yaptım
2 kere 7'den ne geldi 14 birim geldi x
değerimiz olay bu kadar arkadaş tamam
mıyız
hadi bakalım geldim 1ci sorusuna yalnız
ölçme değerlendirme 5'in 1ci sorusuna
onunla devam ediyoruz buradaki soruları
bitirdik mi a ölçme değerlendirme 4'ün
yarısı öbürünün de yarısını almışım
böyle yarım yarım almışım olsun fark
etmez he. Ölçme değerlendirme 5'in ilk
sorusuyla başlayalım. KS paraleldir
KM'ye. Baktım KS mi? PS PS paraleldir
KM'ye. Tamam. Paralellik olmazsa
olmazımız 4 birim 6 birim verildiği
x'indir. Bir dakika burası gerçekten
dikkat etmemiz gereken bir nokta. Çünkü
şu hocam iki tane ben burada benzerlik
gördüm diyebilirsin. Benzerliklerden
birincisini hemen gösteriyorum. Birinci
benzerliğim şu. Burada morla çizdiğim
nedir hocam? kelebek üçgendir. Ama bu
kelebek üçgende oranı yazabiliyor musun
bana? Bak yazamıyorum değil mi? Bunun
buna oranı da verilen başka değer yok.
Yazamadım hocam. Herhalde buradan
çözmüyoruz. O zaman nereden çözeceğiz?
Şuraya bakıyorsun hemen. Etrafını
sarıyla çizdiğim küçük üçgen ve etrafını
sarıyla çizdiğim büyük üçgen. Değil mi?
O zaman ne diyeceksin? Küçüğün büyüğü
oranı. E başka oran da yok hocam. E yine
patladık hocam. Aslında patlamadık.
Buradaki oranlar birleşecek. Nasıl
birleşecek? Misal ben buraya y uzunluğu
diyeyim. Eşitlik dediği için buraya da y
uzunluğu der miyim? Derim. Değil mi?
Bana şunu yazdır arkadaş. Buradaki
üçgen. Hatta şuna da Z uzunluğu diyelim.
Tamam mı? Ben şunu yazmaya çalışıyorum.
Önce kelebek üçgendeki benzerliği
yazacağım sana. Nedir hocam? Küçüğün
büyüğe oranı. Y'nin Z'ye oranı. Eşittir
hocam. Küçüğün büyüğe oranı X'in 6'ya
oranı. İtiraz var mı? Yok. Sildim bunu.
Şimdi yine geldim. Küçüğün büyüğü oranı
küçüğün büyüğü oranına eşit olmak
zorunda. Yani yine y'nin z'ye oranı 4'ün
x + tamamına dikkat et. 4 var, x var, 6
var. Yani 10 + x'e oranına x + 10 da
yazabilirsin. Fark etmez. Bu orana
eşittir. Elimde 2 oran var. Maalesef bu
oranlardan hiçbir şey teker teker elde
edemem. Ama şuna dikkat ediyorum. İkisi
de y/ z oranına eşit mi? Eşit. O zaman
ben bunların da birbirine eşit olduğunu
biliyorum. Yani x/ 6 oranı aslında 4/x +
10 oranına eşittir hocam. İçler dışlar
yaparsak x + 10 = 4 x 6 24. Sen
çarpanlara ayırma biliyorsun. x² + 10x +
pardon 24'ü de bu tarafa at. -24 = 0.
Çarpanlarını ayır bak bana bunu. X'e x
buradan ne gelir? 4 x 6 24. Hocam şuna e
4 x 6 24 yapar da
eee eksiyi sağlayamadık. 3 x 8 24 yaptı.
O da sağlamadı.
Ama x = 2 için sağlıyor değil mi? O
zaman 2'ye 12. Tamam sağladı. Şöyle
sağlar. 2'ye 12 çarpımı 24'ü verir. Şunu
artı şuna eksi verirsem sağlar. x - 2 x
x + 12'nin cevabı 0. Ne zaman cevap 0
gelir bir denklemde? Bu çarpanlardan
biri 0 olduğunda mesela değil mi? x = 2
olabilir. x + 12 = 0'a x = -12 olabilir.
Tabii ki bir kenar uzunluğu negatif
olamayacağına göre o kenar uzunluğu
pozitif olur. Doğru cevabım 2'dir.
Yalnız şuraya kadar getirdiğinde şöyle
de çözülebilir. Eğer cevapların hepsinin
tam sayı olduğunu görürsen. Gördün ya
hocam ben burada x yerine ne yazarsam
sağlar. Bak 2 verdim. 2 verdim. Şurası
12. 2 çarpımı 24. Demek ki x = 2
denebilir. Hani bu da bir taktik ama tam
sayı olması lazım seçeneklerin. Şimdi
KLM üçgeni verilmiş. Paralellik
verilmiş. Paralelliği gördün mü zaten
rahatlıyorsun hemen. Eşit uzunluklar
verilmiş. 9 birim verilmiş. 16 verilmiş.
14 verilmiş. Az önceki teknikle
çözülecek. Bak tek başına şunu veren bir
oran var mı? Yok. O zaman diyorum ki gel
bu kenara ben y diyeyim. Hocam şimdi
buradan çözmeye çalışacağız oranı.
Elimde bir burada üçgenler var. Dikkat
et. Bir büyük bir küçük üçgen. Bir de
burada üçgenler var dikkat et. Bir büyük
bir küçük üçgen. Bunların ortak yanı
KF'nin KR'ye oranları ikisinde de
kullanılıyor. Ben onu kullanarak
çözeceğim soruyu aslında. Bak şimdi
küçüğün büyüğe oranı nereye yazalım?
Şuraya. X'in X + 14'e oranı eşittir
hocam. yazıyorum. 9'un y'ye oranını.
9'un y'ye oranına. Bu oran da eşittir.
Çünkü bak KF'nin KR'ye oranı mesela
yazalım. KF'nin
KR'ye oranına
e aynı şekilde küçüğün büyüğe oranı
küçüğün büyüğe oranına eşittir hocam.
Y'nin 16'ya oranına eşittir. Ben ilk
olarak buradan çözüme başlarsam cevabı
bulurum. Bak içler dışlar çarpımı
yapacağız burada. 9'un y'ye oranı, y'nin
16'ya oranı. İçler dışlar çarpımı
yaptım. y² = 9 x 16. Her tarafın
karekökünü aldım. Y'nin cevabı eşittir 3
x 4. Y'nin cevabı kaçtır? 12. Şimdi
y'nin cevabını burada yerine yazıyorum.
9'un 12'ye oranı e= x'in x + 14'e
oranına eşittir. Şimdi geldim. İçler
dışlar yapacağım ama 9'u 3'e böldüm 3.
12'yi 3'e böldüm kaç kaldı? 4 kaldı.
Şuradan ne geldi? 4x buradan ne geldi?
3x + 3 k 4 12 elimde var 1. Şuradan ne
geldi? 42. Çektim bunu bu tarafa. X e=
cevabı kaç oldu hocam? 42 oldu. O halde
doğru cevabım burada kaç olmalıdır
dedim. C seçeneği. Güzel de cevap oldu
ama tatlı soru be. Çözüyoruz. KLM üçgen.
EF paraleldir LM'ye. KL pardon KP PL'ye
eşit.
4 tane K'ye eşit olduğu verilmiş. Hemen
yazalım.
4 tane K'ye. PE 3 tane K'ye eşit hocam.
Güzel. 6 birim orada. Yukarıda
verilenlere göre Lmx kaç birimdir? LMX'i
arayacağız. Nasıl yaparız hocam acaba?
Nereden geliriz? Şöyle yapalım mı hocam?
Bak burada böyle bir üçgen var. Şöyle
bir kenar var. 4e 3 bölmüş ama tek
başına bir işe yaramıyor. Sanki bir şey
eksik. Hani şu doğru da olsa 4e 3 oran,
6'ya bilmem ne oran. Şak abi ne güzel
denk geliyor. Tesadüf değil tabii bu.
Hemen payda tabana paralel olacak
şekilde çektim. Şimdi yakaladın mı
üçgeni? Hocam 4'ün
7'ye oranı. Hemen yazalım. 4'ün 7K'ye
oranı yani 4K'nin 7K'ye oranı eşittir
tabanlara oranına. Şuraya da y diyelim.
Geçici süreliğine. 6'nın y'ye oranına
eşittir. Burayı yakaladık. K'ler gitti.
4le bunu sadeleştirdim. Burada 2, burada
3 oldu. 2 tane y = 21'den y'nin cevabı
21/2 bulundu. Şimdi bak şu etrafı biraz
temizliyorum. Rahat gör. Şimdi şuranın
cevabı belli hocam. 21/2. Şimdi senden
şunu görmeni istiyorum hocam. Buradaki
küçük üçgenle buradaki büyük üçgen
arasında bir bağlantı var. Nedir o?
Küçüğün büyüğü oranı. Küçüğün büyüğü
oranı. Küçüğün büyüğü oranı. Bu tarafı
sil. Bu taraftaki oran belli. Misal şu
uzunluk m ise buranın tamamı 2m. Hocam
1'e 2 oran var. Yani m'ye 2m oranı var.
Peki burada ne var hocam? Aslında bu
orta taban olmuş oluyor. Yani tabanın
yarısı uzunluğunda 1'e 2 oranı olduğu
için. Ama yine de yazayım. küçüğün
büyüğe oranı. Şu m'ler gitti. İçler
dışlar çarpımı yaptım. X = 21/2 x 2'den
x'in cevabı buradan ne olarak bulunur?
21 olarak bulunur. Doğru cevap ne
olacaktır? A seçeneği olacaktır.
Geldim 4. soruya. Hocam KLM, PLR üçgen.
Paralellikler verildi. 3 var, 6 var, 2
var, 8 var. LS/
SM oranı nedir?
Güzel bir yerden yakalamam lazım şimdi
soruyu. Şimdi kelebek var gibi ama da
yok gibi de hocam. Yani bu böyle mi
devam ediyor acaba? Hani böyle devam
etse daha mı mantıklıymış? Ya da şurada
kesseydik şurada bir kelebek değil mi?
Soru biraz onu hissettiriyor bana. Ben
de diyorum ki dur bakalım herhalde
buradan olabilir. Şöyle bir çektim. Neyi
görmeni bekliyorum senin? Şuradaki
kelebeği görmeni bekliyorum açıkçası.
Gördük mü buradaki kelebeği? Peki bu
oranı yazabilir miyiz? Yazamayız hocam.
Haklısın ama kelebeği gördük en azından.
Ne yapabiliriz? Şuraya mesela T kenarı
desem
6'nın
8'e oranı 6'nın 8'e oranı RT'nin KM'ye
oranına eşittir. Buna hemfikir miyiz?
Kesinlikle hemfikiriz. Şuraya 8 yazdım.
Aa 8'ler sadeleşti. Buraya direkt 6
kaldı. Bitti mi burası? Bitti hocam.
Şimdi benim derdim ne? Bak burada nokta
açısı. nokta açısı. Bak burada atıyorum
çizik açısı, çizik açısı bak burada
küpeli açı, küpeli açı. Hiç gerek yok
bunları yazmama ama zaten gördün. Şimdi
ne yapabilirim hocam? Şunu yaparım
hocam. 3'ün 6'ya oranı 3'ün 6'ya oranı
benzerlik oranı kaçtır? 1/2'dir. O zaman
ben buraya m dersem burası kaç m olmak
zorunda? 2m olmak zorunda. 1'e 2 oran.
Yine başa döndüm. Hani 6'nın 8'e oranı
vardı. Hatırladın mı? Hatırladım hocam.
6'nın 8'e oranı. Yine o oranı bu kenar
içinde yazamaz mıyım? 3m'nin
lm'ye oranı. Oldu mu? Şimdi 2 3'e böldüm
2 3'e böldüm gitti. 2'ye böldüm gitti.
2'ye böldüm 4. İçler dışlar çarpımı
yaptım. LM uzunluğu buradan ne geldi
hocam? 4 tane M geldi. LM'nin tamamına
4m yazacağım. Bak şuradan şuraya 4m
yazacağım. 1 2 3 M'si oradaysa buraya
bir tane M'si kalır mı? Kalır. Buraya da
ne yazmam lazım? Benim M yazmam lazım.
Şimdi şu morlukları siliyorum daha rahat
gör diye. Hocam bizden istenen oran LS
LS'nin oranı M'dir yazdım. SM'nin oranı
3M'dir yazdım. Cevabım da ne olacaktır?
1/3 olacaktır. Doğru cevap 4. soruda A
seçeneğidir. Mis gibi bir soru çözümü
oldu. Geldim 5. soruya. Kelm
üçgen. SR KL birbirine paralel. PN NR KR
R bunlar birbirlerine eşitler. SR'den
NL'yi çıkarttım 4 birim kaldı. Ne alaka
demiyor? Ulan insan düşünüyor. SR'den
NL'yi çıkarttım 4 birim kaldı. KN
uzunluğu nedir? Şimdi ilk baktığımda
benim ben direkt şunu görüyorum mesela.
Hocam bak 1e 2 oran var. Gördün mü? 1e 2
oran. Atıyorum burası k ise hocam burası
2k. Hatta hatta şimdi tersten bak. Ben
çeviremiyorum kafayı ama sen kitabı
tersten bak hocam. 1'e 2 oran. 1'e 2
oran. O zaman bu 2k ise tamamına ne
yazacaksın? 4K. Seri olman lazım. Dur
hocam oranı yazayım. Bırak bunları.
Bırak bunları. Derece tayfa bunu yapmaz.
Derece tayfa olacak mısın? Ya da bunu
izleyen derece tayfa mı? Bak burası 3g
kaldı. Gördün mü? Sildim. Şöyle üstüne
yazayım 3G'yi. X dediğim yer 3G'yi
bulurum. Soru biter. SR'den NL'yi çıkar.
SR'ye 2K dedim. NL'ye K dedim.
Çıkarttım. 4 kaldı. Demek ki K = 4. Soru
benden 3K'yi istiyor. Cevap eşittir 12.
Cevap B seçeneği. Bitti geç. Bitti geç.
Ne görüyorsun? Önceki konulardan dış
açıortay var. Gördün mü? Neyse
geliyorum. Kelm üçgen. KF doğrusal
noktalardır. Paralelliğimiz mevcut.
Nerede o? RP. R nerede? RP paraleldir
hocam. N mi? Tamam. Bu paralellik
önemliydi zaten. Verilen uzunluklar var.
Eşit açı dış açıortay için verilmiş mavi
üçgenin dış açı ortayı burası. Dış
açıortay kuralını ben sana hemen şurada
bir hatırlatayım mı? Şöyle yapmıştık.
Hani şöyle yapmıştık hocam. Bunun buna
oranı bunun buna oranına eşittir. Burası
4, burası 5 ise burası 4k, burası
5k'dir. Hocam şimdi hatırladın mı dış
açıortay teoremine? Şurada dış açıortay
hangi üçgenin dış açıortayı? İçini
karaladığım üçgenin dış açıortayı. O
zaman aynı mantıkla bu 4ile bu 5'in
verilme sebebi dış açıa ortayı
hatırlıyor mu öğrenci? Hatırlıyor.
Nereden neresi? Şuradan şurası. Hocam
buraya 4K, tamamına 5 haliyle buraya ne
kalır? K kalır. Şunları sildim. Soru
bitmiştir efendim. Küçüğün büyüğe oranı
4K pardon K'nin 5K'ye oranı eşit
olmalıdır. 3'ün x'e oranına. 3'ün x'e
oranına. Şunlar gitti. İçler dışlar
yaptım. x = 15 birim geldi. Derece tayfa
bunu çözer. Geçelim sıradakine. Şimdi
ilk sayfadakiler biraz daha kolaydı. Ben
ikinci sayfadakileri daha çok beğendim.
O yüzden buradakilerden çözeceğim.
Biraz yoğurdu ama devam. 25 dakikaları
neredeyse geride bıraktık. Ölçme
değerlendirme 6cısında 5. sorudayım.
Aşağıda kolunlukları 12 36 cm olan iki
maşa şeklinde konumlandırılmıştır.
MN kaç birimdir? Bence bu soru güzel.
Bak şimdi şurada bir ikizkenar
görüyorsun. Güzel. Burada da bir
ikizkenar görüyorsun. Açıyla başla.
Belki görme şansın artar. Hocam şuna
alfa açısı dersem şuna da alfa açısı
dersem şimdi burası ikizkenar. Alfayya
alfa doğru. Büyük üçgene bak. Bu da
ikizkenar. Burası alfaysa şurası da
alfa. Hocam gördün mü? Güzel. Bana şunu
söyle hani yazayım istersen. Eee L K M
üçgeni benzerdir.
N K L üçgenine. Kabul müyüz? Gerçekten
ikizkenar bu üçgenler birbirine benzer
üçgenlerdir. Şimdi başlıyorum bak. Küçük
üçgenden başlıyorum. Şurada hocam
alfanın karşısında kaç var? 12 var.
Büyük üçgende alfanın karşısında büyük
üçgen dediğim bu kaç var? 36 var.
Eşittir mn'yi istiyorsun sen benden. Bak
ben oraya x dedim. Tamamı 36. Buraya ne
kaldı? 36 - x kaldı. Şurada tepe açısına
da gel nokta açısı diyelim.
Nasıl oluşuyor? Alfa alfa nokta alfa
alfa. Şu açı ne olacaktır? Nokta açısı
olacaktır. O zaman şunu söylüyorum.
Noktanın karşısında küçük üçgende 36 - x
var. Noktanın karşısında büyük üçgende
12 var. Güzel. Şimdi sadeleştirme.
36 12 sadeleşti. 3 3 12 sadeleşti. O da
eşittir 36 - x. x = buradan işlemleri
yaptığımızda ne gelecektir? 36'dan 4
çıktı. Özür dilerim. 4 çıkınca ne kalır?
32 kalır. Doğru cevap E seçeneğidir. Bak
bu soru güzel. İşlem çok demiyorum.
Sorunun güzelliği oradaki gizli olan
benzer üçgenlerde. Misal bak burada da
bir gizli bir şeyler var. Ya da bir tık
daha böyle hemen baktığında
göremeyeceğin soru. Yukarıdaki şekilde
ön yüzü mavi, arka yüzü sarı olan KLM
üçgeni biçimindeki kağıdın L köşesinden
KP boyunca katlanmış hali gösteriliyor.
1536 gösteriliyor. LP kaç birimdir? LP
dediğim yer neresi? Burası. Buranın
uzunluğunu istiyorum arkadaş. diyor ki
ben diyor aldım KL'yi L köşesinden
tuttum R'nin üzerine katladım. Hocam
burada bu tarz bir katlama yapıldıysa ve
burası 90°erece ise burası da 90'dır.
Kabul mü? Bunu aldım buraya katladım.
Demek ki KL uzunluğu 15 birimse KR
uzunluğu da kaç birimdir? 15 birimdir.
LP'yi aldım buraya katladım. Demek ki
bunun uzunluğuna diyelim ki ben X dersem
burası da X'tir. Şunun tamamına LM'ye
kaç dedin? 36. Buraya ne kalır hocam? 36
- x kalır. Şimdi biraz açılarla
oynayalım. Ne yapabilirim diye hani
bakıyorum. Büyük üçgene baktım. Yani
büyük dik üçgene baktım. Büyük. Hocam
ben şuna alfa demek istiyorum. Şuna beta
demek istiyorum. Kabul mü?
Küçük. Bak şimdi büyük dik üçgen. Şu
küçük dik üçgen. Alfa beta. Alfa. Neresi
beta hocam? Şurası beta. Diyorum ki
küçük dik üçgende büyük dik üçgen benzer
üçgenlerdir. Niye? Açı açı benzerliği.
Üç açısının da eşit olduğunu buldum.
Dedim ki bunlar birbirine benzerdir.
Hocam ama bunu yapabilmek için şu üçgeni
sana hatırlatmam lazım galiba. 5 12 13
dik üçgeni. Ne alaka hocam bu soruyla?
Bunu 5 3ile çarp. 3 x 5 15. Bunu 3le
çarp 36. Bunu 3le çarp 39. Ne demek
istediğim galiba anlaşıldı. Bak hocam
buranın tamamı 39. Yakaladın mı? 39'dan
15 çıktı. 9'dan 5 çıktı 4. Şurada ne
kaldı? 24. Artık soruyu bitirme vakti.
Hocam küçük üçgende alfanın karşısına x,
büyük üçgende alfanın karşısına ne
yazdım? 15 yazdım. Küçük üçgende betanın
karşısına 24.
Büyük üçgende betanın karşısına kaç
yazdık? 36 yazdık. Soru x'i bulmak
üzerineydi ve biz de x'i artık buradan
bulabiliriz. 4'e böldüm 6 4e böldüm 9
3'e böldüm 2 3'e böl 12'ye bölebilirdik
ya 12'ye böldük 3. 3'e böldüm gitti 3'e
böldüm 5 kaldı 2 kaldı içler dışlar
yaptım x = 2 kere 5'ten ne geldi 10
geldi. Bizden lp'yi istiyor. Doğru değil
mi? LP uzunluğuna biz X demiştik. Doğru
cevap 10. Gördünüz mü? Bak kalite soru
nasıl ortaya çıkıyor. Buradaki sorular
güzel. Buradaki sorular güzel. 7 de çok
güzel. Şekil 1'deki KLM üçgeni L köşesi
tabanına ait yükseklik boyunca kesilip
iki parçaya ayrılıyor. Bu parça şekil
2'deki gibi yerleştiriliyor. KLM 100
birim, KM 120 birim. Yukarıdaki verilere
göre K üssü P kaç birimdir? K üssü P. K
üssü P. Burayı soruyorsun hocam. Güzel.
Orayı buluyorsun. Bir şey söyleyeceğim.
Kelm üçgeni L köşesinden tabanına
yüksekliği boyunca L köşesinden tabanına
yüksekliği çizdim.
Nasıl üçgen? Dik yok ikizkenar üçgen.
100'e 100 ya. Ne yapar? Tabanı 2 eşit
parçaya böler. Yetmez hocam bu. Aynı
zamanda bak 100 var 60 var. 6 8 10
üçgeni 3 4 5 üçgeninin katları ya da 60
80 100 üçgeni fark etmiyor. Diyor ki ben
bu parçayı aldım diyor daha farklı
yerleştirdim diyor. Yani onun dik kenarı
buraya gelecek şekilde koydum diyor.
Mesela şunlara çızık açısı dersek buraya
çızık açısı şuraya da diyor hadi çızık
yapmayalım da alfaya beta yapalım. Tamam
mı? Şunlar beta olsun. Şu ikiz kenarın
eşitlikleri alfa olsun. Mesela m açısı
alfa 90. Şuraya ne kaldı? Bet. Şuraya ne
kaldı? Alfa. Yakalayabildim mi
üçgenleri? Şimdi bildiğim bütün kenar
uzunluklarını yazacağım. Hocam şurası
tabandı bizim. 80. Şuranın tamamı kaçtı?
100. Bir kenar uzunluğu. Burası bizim
tabandı. 60. Pardon. Şuraya da 60
yazacaktım. Karıştırdım. Neden? Bak
buraya dikme attığımız yer şu parça. Bu
parça aslında o 60 olan. Tamam. 100
neresi hocam başka? Şurası soruda.
Benden burayı mı istiyor? K üssü P.
Doğru. Burayı istiyor. X.
Eee, şu parçaya dikkat et. KH. KH dediği
yer şurası aslında bizim için. K üssü H
dediği yer. Eee, onu nasıl alabilirim
hocam? 80 olarak alacağım. Şuraya ne
kalacak? 80 - x kalacak galiba. Şimdi
daha güzel oldu. 80 - x olarak aldım.
Şimdi de diyorum ki kritik yerdeyim.
Biraz yavaş hareket etmeye çalışıyorum.
Burada şu içerisini yeşille boyadığım
üçgen. Evet. Hocam bir de bana büyük bir
üçgen lazım. Bütün kenar uzunluklarının
bilindiği, x'i oradan rahat rahat
çekebileceğim. Bence çektik. Mesela şu
üçgen benzer midir hocam? Benzerdir.
Başlayalım. Mesela alfanın karşısında 60
var. Yazdım. Alfanın karşısında ortadaki
kenar olan 80 var. Şu eşittir betanın
karşısında 80 - x var. Beta yine burası.
Betanın karşısında büyük üçgende 60 var.
Sadeleştirmeler var. Şunlar gitti.
Eee, 8 4e böldüm 2. 4e böldüm 15 2'ye
böldüm gitti 2'ye böldüm 3. İçler dışlar
çarpımı 80 - x = 15'i 3le çarpıyoruz
yanlış yapmayalım. 45 x buradan ne
gelecektir? 35 gelecektir. Yine şıkırı
şıkırı bir sorudur bu. İşte geometri.
Bak burada bir ısınma oldu mu? Olduysa
doğru gidiyoruz arkadaşlar. Güzel
gidiyoruz demektir. Geldim 8. soruya.
Benim çözeceğim son süre. Süremiz de
bayağı oldu zaten. Yol kenarında yere
dik konumlu kare biçimde uyarı levhası
çıkan fırtınayla yere değecek şekilde
dengede kalmış. RP direği levhaı KN
kenarının orta noktası olan R noktasına
monte edilmiştir. Direğin kalınlığı
önemsesi hiç önemli değil. MN 40 birim,
PR birim, L üssü, Mssü, F doğruları
doğrusal olduğuna göre Pf kaç birimdir?
Şimdi baktım hocam şurası direğin orta
konumu diyor. Yani şu parçayla şu parça
birbirine eşit mi? Ben bunu anlıyorum.
MN uzunluğu 40 birim. Kare biçiminde
dediğine göre şunlar 20 birim mi? Yani
şu parçaya 20 yazsam bir şey demem
herhalde. Şu parçaya da 40 yazsam bu iş
tamamdır. Oraya da 40'ımı yazdım.
Direğin uzunluğu diyor. Şuraya da 50 mi
yazdım? Kabul müyüz buraya kadar her
şeyle? Kabul. Şimdi benim artık şuna
karar vermem lazım. Hocam burada
gördüğüm sarı üçgenle acaba burada
gördüğüm sarı üçgenler birbirine benzer
midir? Niye? Şurası 90. Şurası 90.
Geldim şuraya alfa dedim. E bu 90°
diyelim ki bu beta olsun. Alfa beta 90
yapıyor. Haliyle buraya alfa buraya da
beta açısı kalıyor. Bunlar ince içtilik
gerektiriyor. Şimdi diyorum ki PF kaç
birimdir diyor. PF buranın tamamı oraya
gitmeye çalışacağız ama adım adım
gidelim. Önce ben şu kenar uzunluğunu
bulacağım. Bak şuraya Y uzunluğu dedim.
Betanın karşısı 20, betanın karşısı Y.
Alfanın karşısı 50. Alfanın karşısı 40.
Ufak bir sadeleştirme şunlar gitti
hocam. 5te bu sadeleşti. 4. Y'nin cevabı
ne geldi? 16. Bak burası 16 geldi. Artık
tamamen Pisagor. Misal şuraya A
uzunluğu, şuraya B uzunluğu dersem
üçgenlerde Pisagor yapacağım. A'² = 50
kares + 20 kares. Burada da ne var
aslında bak. 10un kares x 5in kares 2
kares x 10un kares yakaladın mı bunu?
Uzun uzun sakın a karelerini aldım
falan. Çıkılmaz abi işin içinden. 10un
karesi parantezine aldım. 5 kares + 2
kares e 10un karesi 100'dür. 5 kares + 2
kares 29'dur. Karşı taraf a karedir. Her
tarafın karekökünü aldığımda a = 100
dışarı 10 diye çıkar. √29 içeride kalır.
Kabul mü? Geldim buraya hocam. Elimde ne
var? B'nin karesi var. B'nin karesi neye
eşit? 40 kares + 16 karesi. Sakın ha tek
tek alırsın karelerini. Bitirirsin bizi
burada ha. 5 kere 8 40 değil mi? 8 kares
x 5 kares + 2 x 8 16 8 kares x 2 karesi.
Derece tayfa kaptık değil mi olayı? 8in
karesi parantezine alırım. 8in karesi
parantezinde 5 kares + 2 karesi. 8in
karesi nedir? 64. E 5in karesi 25. 2in
karesi 4. Topla 29. B'nin karesi buysa
her tarafın karekökünü aldım. B = 8 x
√29.
8√29. Öyle saçma duruyor tabii de. Şu
ikisini topladığımızda ne yapacaktır?
10' la 8√29'u
18√29 doğru cevap D seçeneğidir. Mis
gibi bir soru daha biter. Eller öper
arkadaş. Evet sizlerle birlikte böyle
güzel de sorularımızı da çözmüş olduk.
Artık yeni üniteye geçiyorum. Daha
doğrusu yeni alt başlığımıza geçiyorum.
Şöyle bir bakıyorum. Nedir o? Öglit
bağıntılarına geçeceğim. İnşallah
okuldaki hocanıza da yetiştiğimizi
düşünüyorum arkadaşlar. Ama hedef 3
milyon. Hala abone olmalıysan lütfen
abone ol. Abone olmayan arkadaşlar varsa
onları da teşvik edersen sevinirim. Ve
artık neler başlıyor? 9. sınıf konu
tarama denemelerimiz başlıyor. Onları da
hafta sonları getirmeye, elimden
geldiğince yetiştirmeye çalışacağım.
Aman diyeyim kaçırma. Kendine iyi bak.
Hoş kal. Hoşça kal.
>> [müzik]
[müzik]
>> H